In our national lead.
The writers and actors
strike that as ground
Hollywood production to a halt for months
drags on.
The actor union SAG-AFTRA
joined the Writers
Guild of America strike in July
and many of the same issues
that drove writers to strike
are also shared by actors.
The demand for a fair working wage
and job protections as streaming
has upended the entertainment industry.
And joining me now to discuss is two time
Tony and six
time Emmy Award winning
actor Bryan Cranston,
a friend of the show.
I think it's fair to say, Bryan,
thanks for joining us.
Are you encouraged at all
that major studios
are set to resume talks
with the Writers Guild?
And where do talks
stand with SAG after the Actors Guild
And do actors
want to see that that table?
Oh, we certainly do.
Thanks for having me, Jake.
Good to see you again.
The writers have
been out for almost or around
for months, the actors for two.
It's always a good sign
when you're invited to
to get back
to the negotiating table
as far as the after SAG end of it.
We've been asking the AMPTP to be a part
of these negotiations
and to come back to the table.
And thus far, they have refused to accept
that invitation.
We try not to be pessimistic about that.
Our sister, Union Writers
Guild of America,
they are going back
apparently next week, and it's hopeful.
I mean, any time
you're actually sitting at the table,
something can happen.
If you're not talking,
nothing can happen. Yeah.
Both the writers
and the actors unions
have visually been united,
as demonstrated
by a large joint
rally in Los Angeles Wednesday.
Do you think that unity is going to hold
if if one side reaches an
agreement before the other?
I hope it does.
We we are so related in our storytelling
capacity that it it does behoove us
and helps each others to stay united.
I hope that we do.
We have some slight different issues
than the Writers Guild have,
but for the most part,
I would say 75, 80% of
their issues are also our issues as well.
A lot of that has to do
with how streaming has upended
the business model on which
so many careers
and lifestyles were were built.
The industry was built.
Let me play this clip.
This hopefully can help us
and our audience understand some of this.
This is from your friend
and fellow Breaking Bad costar, actor
Aaron Ball.
Aaron Paul, take a listen.
The show's live, live forever.
All these streamers.
It goes through waves, you know.
And I mean,
I just saw just the other day
the Breaking Bad was trending on Netflix.
And it's just it's such common sense.
And I think a lot of these streamers,
they know that they have been
getting away with not paying people
just fair wage
and now it's time to pony up.
So it might be tough
for people to understand
breaking Bad is airing on Netflix.
It was originally on AMC
and now it's on Netflix.
And actors aren't getting paid for it.
Well, they're if you literally,
figuratively, you are getting paid.
But the scale is so far below
what we're used to
There used to be several
different revenue streams
for a working actor
to cobble together
to actually make a living.
And you needed all of them
to be able to do that.
Well, those have been whisked away.
And what was called New Media years ago
now, the streaming market,
we know what it is.
And we know that all the legacy studios
have switched their entire business model
to become part of that contest.
To be a leader in the streaming wars.
And it has created a situation
where the AMPTP is taking
an old and out modeled business model and
coming up
with their
contract offers, according to that.
Well, everything is changed
This business has changed demonstrably.
So we need to look at
what are the new situations
that we're dealing with,
what are the new rules
that we're playing by
and come up with new agreements that that
answer to that.
There's also the simple fact
that about five weeks ago,
The New York Times did an exposé on the
the rents in Los Angeles
from 2000 to two to 23
and they showed that rents in Los
Angeles went up 35% on average.
At the same time,
the increase in pay went up only 6%.
So it doesn't take a mathematician
to realize
that inflation
has had a tremendous effect
on the working actor.
Yeah.
And I know one of the other
big sticking points
is, for instance, on Netflix,
you don't even know
how many people are watching
because Netflix does not share the data.
That is one of the big sticking points
for the writers.
And the actors let you know
because the ratings
used to be the way
that the networks would let people know
that was all public
and that that information
is now being guarded.
That's true in an unbelievable way.
Bryan Cranston, always good to see you.
Thank you so much.
We all hope that this strike end soon
and that living wages are paid.
Thank you.